[Music]
Khloe Kardashian is trying to stay
positive when it comes to brother Rob's
drama with his ex blac Chyna in a new
clip from Keeping Up with the
Kardashians Kim and Khloe have a
heart-to-heart about the former couple's
ongoing legal battle
listen there's a plus and a minus one of
the plus of all this there's no way
Robin trying to get back together after
this right totally let's focus on the
positive yeah
the negative is all of this other right
now
[Music]
the negative is just that like as Rob
having sisters he should just know
better and he could have just like he
should have just like controlled himself
Kym is seemingly referring to the
aftermath of Rob sharing nude photos of
his ex online after she allegedly
cheated on him I would like to first and
foremost thank you judge for granting me
this restraining order to protect me and
I'm just gonna get back to co-parenting
dreams though Rob and Chyna are no
longer together they still share one
year old daughter dreams they obviously
still have to communicate for the
custody of dream but you know what
they're still having a hard time getting
along I feel like this is escalating to
a place that none of us could have ever
imagined but it just sucks the keys made
out to this bad guy when she's taunting
him like love makes you do tough things
do you think anyone's proud of that no
you don't put someone's heart and
emotion
[Music]